you never know you're going corner shop
i might just click you thought you got
away yeah yeah we were playing you
thought we were playing run me my five
m's back now yeah
i've spent loads aberdeen yeah
six o'clock yeah before you want to
collect it
you'll be white as a ghost family
family i beg
and beg the donny behind the counter to
save me
[Music]
what's cracking lacking what's going on
cult members it's monday funday you
already know what it is you cheating
with your boys
uh j
money fire
come on man um
you know the vibes you know the drill
um we've got the don julio mugs out
today we've got the chairs as well oh
yeah the new comfy chairs new comfy
comps yeah yeah so we're we're ready now
we've got that lumbar support and we're
ready to bring the smoke um but before
we do guys you already know
you need to take a second pause the
episode right now and scurry on over to
patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs
um and that's gonna cost you a measly
three pound a month 10p a day run the p
and they're going to get over two years
worth of content on there lots of jokes
lots of close times lots of pick your
poison games uh we just recorded an
episode just now um for this thursday
and it's it's juicy juice um so guys
patreon.com four star shits and gigs
head on over there now um
and binge some extra content new episode
every single thursday over there uh guys
if you're watching this on youtube make
sure
you use the two fingers of death to
flick that bell
get the notifications every time we
upload because we're uploading hot and
fast shit's just moving we just move
movers
yeah we're renegades man we're running
games we just do
what we want when we want uh and we just
can't warn you every time so make sure
the notifications are on make sure you
are subscribed and make sure your chirps
emitting in the comments there over on
youtube and as always guys if you're
listening to the smooth mellow sounds of
your boys over on whether it be spotify
apple podcast google podcast amazon
music whatever it is
make sure to leave us a review make sure
you subscribe to the channel on there
leave us a review it does wonders um for
our growth um
we're starting
picking out spots for 2023
uh we've got a few
cult locations figured out for the log
cabin so guys um we just need the funds
now yeah we need the white robes and
uses is not cheap uniform
it's really not yeah and we obviously
need backup yeah it's going to say
everyone needs a couple of years it gets
dirty easily yeah we can't just have
everyone stalk stalkers while you're
washing your robe so
yeah we're going to need a few pairs for
everyone this is that we didn't
anticipate the budget to be so high so
guys please again help us grow help us
reach new ears and
eyes and hop on over to patreon and uh
yeah fund your boys as well standard
yeah um but without any further ado guys
uh fujad is gonna hit us with some funny
funds off the bat uh and let us know
what we're what we're laughing at today
bro come on bro so there's this thing
that i saw it said man rush to icu after
crunching lung while masturbating too
hard
you heard about this i feel like i did
hear about it but i haven't read it but
that sounds familiar crunch what do you
mean crunching along fan crunched
that's what a thing said what do you
mean
i might let you know
a 20 year old man was left in intensive
care after a fake accident happened
whilst he was masturbating the swiss
patient who
who remains unnamed presumably out of
embarrassment
suffered a rare like a rare lung injury
usually caused by rigorous exercise or
violent coughing
he was hospitalized for three days and
spent a night in icu as the air had
escaped from his lung and became trapped
sorry became lodged in his rib cage
the patient took himself to a e after
experiencing breathlessness and chest
pains while he was performing the act in
his bed
when he arrived at the hospital it was
clear he had really done a number on
himself his face was swollen and
crunching noises were coming from his
neck down to his arms
noises were coming from his neck down to
his arms brother the doctors diagnosed
him with spontaneous
pneumomedia stenum
in brackets spm
which is which is the leakage of air
from the lungs to the ribs
bro so man was just fapping he wasn't
gutted
him
[ __ ]
literally and then long just collapsed
collapse
i just crunched fat it must have been
he's probably fourth or fifth or sixth
one of the day he was trying to get it
out yeah yeah he was he had he had an
hour window he had a lunch break
i'm yeah and going
what would you okay if you were the
spreader yeah let's say you were in the
comfort of your home no lunch break
nothing
comfort your home
you nutted and you felt like
what would you do
are you going to the hospital knowing
the kind of second-hand embarrassment
it's not your second is firsthand
embarrassment you would receive there's
a lot of things i wouldn't go to the
hospital for but my lung crunching 100
i'm going
100 feet i'm going but obviously you're
not going there you're calling my man on
the phone you're calling them ambulance
yeah come and get me what are you
telling them swag one what are you
telling me until i was doing press-ups
for science
i was doing a hit workout on youtube and
my lung crunch i don't know what i'm
turning from i'm not saying i was
wanking
i'll just i won't give him details i'll
build him
okay cool
you'll you're let's do a role play yeah
to get my message across yeah so i'm
gonna punch my lungs yeah and you're the
operator on the
on the on the end of the thing right
[Applause]
[Music]
hello thomas hospital
please
hello
please help hello sir calm down sir
who's speaking what's your name it's
thomas thomas thomas thomas where are
you calling from yard
thomas i need you to be specific where
are you calling from can't read
thomas
thomas
thomas
thomas where are you calling from i need
to send an ambulance where are you oh
three one three smith street smith
street tell us what's wrong we're on our
way we've sent an ambulance but can you
tell me what's wrong so i can fill out
the details so you don't have to explain
yourself again i was exercising okay and
my lung it crunch what what sort of
exercise were you doing sir
rigorous
i need i'm going to need more specifics
shut up man please
i'm begging you please thomas please
please tell us you're asking too much
thomas thomas sharon
sharon
i'm warning this guy right now sharon
if i hang up this phone
they're gonna say i killed someone
sharon
so please
come and take this phone off me
hello speaking
sharon is quenching your colleagues
she's asking too much of man i can't
breathe i can't see well she hold on sir
she's told me anything it's not
everywhere
there's what's theresa
sharon i can't breathe please i was
exercising regularly i told her yes yes
thomas calm down yeah one first and
foremost the ambulance is on the way
three four three nine three one three
smith street that's all i know today
thank you
thank you so much i'd love to fill any
details but like i said can't breathe
but thank you
i need to thank you again
what were you doing
exercising rigorously but i need more
specifics what exercise are they here
yet sharon
sharon have they arrived they're five
minutes out smith five minutes oh thomas
sorry they're five minutes out thomas i
don't know if i'm gonna make it can you
can you please hang up the phone and
call her matana to hurry up please
sharon wait that's not our procedure
thank you
god bless you sharon
[Laughter]
i don't know where sharon came from
you [ __ ] sweeted
yo
[ __ ] that's top three funniest things
you've said in this podcast bro [ __ ]
that made me laugh
the [ __ ] that made me laugh oh [ __ ] you
gotta say i killed someone
oh [ __ ]
bro that's too funny
that was a [ __ ] funny scenario
jesus yeah if i'm i'm not telling them
you're gonna have to some uh i'm telling
them i was exercising okay what lies
would you give what exercise were you
doing burpees
i was holding a plank or something i
don't know i was going to say more
plague than yeah i was out i was
thinking about the burpee
yeah maybe possibility
yeah i would tell him i was holding a i
was trying to do a world record plank
satin
and then it just crunched
but i'll deflect fam i'll deflect
there's no way you're telling them
you're not you're knocking off yeah
there's no way
even if they're like bro when we got
there there was not all on your knees
only in your chest on your knees ah
because you can't clean up yeah you're
dead
true
i forget you're you can't move brother
yeah that might have to carry you out
yeah and in place you want a stretcher
uh there's not everywhere brother you
can't lie you can't lie your way out of
that you can't
i'll say the paramedics are [ __ ]
liars
i don't know why they'd say that
but those are the questions you need to
be asking don't ask me those kind of
questions
your paramedics are liars
um
you're probably wondering what's in this
cup none your business
juice
oh dear that's hilarious so we've got
the um what's the q a today
so we've got two q a's this episode guys
you're welcome
um
the first one i got i either got it off
socials i.e like twitter or something or
someone sent it to me
in the dms about a
a specific topic i just wrote all the
answers down i think comment it could
have been comments from a tick tock all
right i think it's comments from a tick
tock comments from tick tocks are
literally the best thing of all time i
think they sometimes i think they
they're better than twitter
sometimes yes i agree i do agree
sometimes they i feel like people on
twitter are sometimes are trying too
hard
agreed i think like i feel like tick
tock comments people just say because
like it's off the cuff
it's only yeah on tick tock you can't
predict what's going to get whoever has
the most likes on the comments goes to
the top straight away but you don't know
if that's going to be you of course
you're just sharing your experience of
course i think on twitter people know
people are going to see it yeah so they
try and think of like sometimes it
doesn't it doesn't slap for me that
makes sense
right this is just a short this is a
short one we'll do a longer one at the
end with the other questions um so this
one is weirdest slash ickiest thing a
guy has said during the deed
he came and whispered
thank you
thank you
thank you
oh
to be fair i've probably thanked someone
before
i've high fived the trick before have
you yeah post obviously post post nut
was it uh
like you've cleaned up and high-fived or
you're you literally you're still inside
her no no no no no like wait
we've like huh both of us yeah yeah and
i just looked at that that was [ __ ]
banging
bang
live okay m ones i've given one of them
he told me to say his name
his name was doug
[Laughter]
doug nah that's dread that's not even
his fault there's nothing he can do
about that what there is
change that yeah basically his name was
doug the fact that she was so confident
that universally we know there's a [ __ ]
name that all she had to do was say his
name was his name was doug doug oh my
goodness i didn't even know people could
still call people doug nah same he told
me
you just came
i don't even know what he meant because
i definitely didn't was he manifesting
you just came
that's aggressive
why would you say that to someone you
just came you just came
like say she didn't she she might not
know
she didn't feel it yeah sometimes it was
an out of body experience doesn't know
about the phantom nuts
them ghosts
he started counting with every thrust
one two three four five wow
imagine one
two
three [ __ ] hell that's grim that is
grim
he was probably thinking i need to i
need to get to 56 and i know what my
mark is yeah i know what my market is if
i surpassed that
for a long year yeah as long as i can
get past 56 we're golden i won't hit the
group chat if i could just make it to
56. if he is all focused he doesn't know
if he's thinking or speaking
if the stroke is so good you don't know
what's going on you just need to focus
if he's thinking or speaking i just eat
it
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] it oh that's hilarious that's
hilarious
sometimes he says my first and last name
that's disgusting
that's disgusting
that's literally disgusting imagine a
girl riding you and saying james duncan
james
no no no no no get the [ __ ] off me
that's insane bro
quotations you're taking it well
end quotes it was very small you're
taking it well
like i'm impressed with this
mosquial can't hold it
shameful behavior it was very small
he stopped
he farted then kept going
literally three seconds
he said guide me in soldier
what guide
your face guide me in soldier
just close his eyes
some stevie thing
where are you
what's that look marker
mark
[Laughter]
that's hilarious
my ex started laughing and said sorry i
was thinking about batman
do you know for the guy or a girl
sorry i was thinking about batman i
can't remember if it was a girl not
present
not present fam just not involved oh
[ __ ] sake
is such a paradox
he called me a human fleshlight
well i mean technically yeah
but
that's savage that is savage
you're a human fleshlight
i don't need the rest of you anything i
just need from torso to patella yeah
that's all i need from you
just shut up
shove and take it
let me not and let me do it human
fleshlight wow wow ally wow
stated how close he was coming in
percentages
i said i'm 65
65
i'm 77 there
wow slap him wow
the [ __ ]
um
he was on top
i closed my eyes and he said where are
you going
oh bro
certain man went just weren't raised
they weren't raised right period
period where are you going
he didn't say anything or make any noise
whatsoever that was the ick
fair play that is very fair i've never
been silent like silent that's that's
hard work that's scary yeah yeah
imagine a thing and she's just silent no
no no no no no no no on entry nothing no
heavy breathing no nothing nah i'm done
that's mind-boggling yeah that's uh
necrophiliac it is i'm not about it
it is
[ __ ] you know
he asked me to talk dirty to him in
spanish i'm filipino
man said he just wants my fantasy for
films yo
oh jesus i need that fantasy
you're not white speak spanish now
[Laughter]
oh that's too funny
that was too funny
jesus
i asked him whose [ __ ] this is and he
said it's yours
[Laughter]
because she's thinking big man you're
killing the whole tape and he's thinking
you're asking me silly little questions
i'm trying to pipe you're asking me
[ __ ] rhetoricals
oh my back's hurting now man that's
[ __ ] funny
oh [ __ ]
asked me to talk dirty to him out of
nowhere and when i paused he said
where's your confidence
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
that one got me just quotes you're
crushing me
jesus
he said
don't look at me
during the deed don't look at me don't
look at me
a girl can never tell me that don't look
at me once i'm inside i say don't look
at me
i'll be so confused brother bro i'll be
so upset
don't look at me i'd be so confused just
bang me stop just i don't need you
i just need that
no look at me don't talk to me don't
touch don't breathe on you yeah yeah
yeah yeah stewie needs to do nut and
[ __ ] off
scum your scum just bang me and piss off
i just heard you got a tool yeah yeah
use it and [ __ ] off
and that was it that was just a little
short that was funny bro that wasn't
that was surprisingly funny oh my god
that got me what's up guys
um
just going to take a very quick break
from the episode to show some love to
our boys over at manscaped so guys to
start off your spring cleaning
use the manscaped lawn mower 4.0 trimmer
to get the most precise shave on your
hedges bruv you know the vibes you know
the vibes we spoke about it enough um
but did we mention it's waterproof as
well i'm pretty sure we did but we need
to tell them again for the people in the
back it's waterproof as well so no need
to worry about watering your grass with
this tool
it's also equipped with an led light so
you know it'll be a major asset to the
new shower routine bravo get all the
nooks and crannies and get in there nice
and deep like
so guys you know what you need to do
you need to pause the episode head on
over to manscape.com
use the code sng sierra november golf
uh and that's going to get you 20 off
and free shipping worldwide one more
time that's the code sng sierra november
gold manscape.com land yourself 20 off
and free shipping grab that lawnmower
4.0 trim those hedges it's time to clap
cheeks
white robes and uses the waiting come on
guys let's get back to the episode
right i have gotten am i the [ __ ] hit
me
it's an interesting one hit me no give
me a second let me find it this one this
is an interesting one okay here we go
right
so i've got another [ __ ]
i met a japanese girl who was going to
the local college in california
we started dating for some reason i
already know she's banging i don't know
why yeah probably i just have that
feeling probably japanese in california
yeah
just happens to be that way yeah
right we started dating and i was set to
move to new york city for work and i
convinced her to transfer schools and
move with me
once she arrived in new york she started
acting different and we got into several
fights
um which we never did before
on my birthday night she drops a huge
bomb at me at 4am i'm completely drunk
almost blacked out we're walking home
from the bar and she says remember my
friend in japan who was in the yakuza
he just got out of jail after 10 years
i said okay
yeah i remember the story yeah what
about it so glad he's out god bless
then she goes
so i invited him to come stay at your
apartment in new york
whose apartment homeboys
she's he said horror
this man fresh out of 10 years in jail
member of one of the biggest crime
organizations in the world in my
apartment man hasn't said man hasn't had
sex with a girl in a decade
i feel fear in my chest
right
i feel fear in my chest
i start asking her who the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
piss off
right
i start asking her who the [ __ ] is this
person to you yeah is this your
ex-boyfriend there's no way you would
just invite some friend fresh out of
prison
uh you haven't seen in 10 years to my
apartment
halfway across the world have you been
planning this with him all along she
gets super defensive won't tell me a
thing when we get back home i tell her
start talking or start walking
if you won't tell me the full story
right now then i don't want you in my
apartment you're putting my life at risk
facts
she tells me to go [ __ ] myself packs her
things and leaves at 5am
so basically man wants to know is he the
[ __ ] for
reacting that way kicking her out no not
in the slightest
the accuser
to his yard
not even oh i've got a friend that i
haven't seen in 10 years staying at my
yard i hope you're okay with it
his yard no he's not the [ __ ]
nobody's not yours how dare you invite
someone let alone
someone that's been to jail for 10 years
that's in the yakuza to my yard how dare
you yeah it's not happening it's not
happening no you're not the also brother
yeah yeah yeah
never in a million years yakuza
you can never tell me you even know
someone in yakuza you couldn't you
couldn't i already know i'm in the wrong
circle yeah oh yeah you need to be
associated with such yeah about that
life i don't want to be about that life
literally i'm trying to choose
that's bellies and bats on the side yeah
that's real that's real that's shanks
and nunchucks on site yeah that's a real
nah i'm not on it i'm not on it yeah
some tokyo drifting i'm not on stuff
like that no no
don't give it i have to say is you got
my dress or not tell me now
none of this [ __ ] yourself you're
leaving i'm closing the door does he
have my dress or not
slamming it
[ __ ] tell me tell me immediately
[ __ ] tell me oh that was scare me
yakuza
imagine she's dipped all right let's say
she's dipped now this whole breakup's
happening wherever she's gone
you're you've um
we've got a few days it's been like a
week now nothing's happened
and then you just hear you're at home
sunday night you just hear your buzzer
you live on the seventh floor yeah
you're not expecting anybody it's seven
o'clock sunday night
chilling the sun's out you're relaxing
and you're with your ting you can see
the face in the com on the comms thing
you can see the face got a camera so you
go to this thing you don't say hello you
just see
you see a yakuza esque looking type
breader yakuza
looking type breader just japanese bread
with sunglasses and a leather jacket
leather jacket and yeah
a couple tears and you see just like a
nectar here nah i'm all right
keep keep ringing it
i mean he looks
when you're in your apartment looking at
the camera he looks at the camera and
takes his glasses off
and he brings it and he because you can
hear him press it i know you're in there
i know open up she told me everything i
know they're [ __ ] in there
and then you look out your balcony you
can see but you peek you peek out your
balcony you you're on the seventh floor
but you're crawling yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah of course you're stuck at this
point
you're crawling to the balcony you climb
you make your way up to the actual thing
you look over you can just see him
are you really [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] what do i do what do i do what do i
do what do you do fam
i'll air him for at least 15 minutes
he's not going anywhere he's just cool
he's just been out of jail yeah he's got
time he's got patience he's got time yet
all right cool he's got nowhere to be no
no literally nowhere else to be all
right bear only address he has is your
address he's got nowhere else i said i
spoke to kimako she told me everything
she hasn't eaten in weeks
you're [ __ ]
open the [ __ ] door just wanna chat
open the door i just wanna chat he's got
a suitcase i just wanna chat
i'll say bro
i don't wanna beat around the bush i'm
sorry well if she told you i'm sorry so
wait how are you talking how are you
communicating from the balcony
i've got a closer look bro i'm sorry
yeah
but i don't want to be any part of this
i just don't
and he says all right cool bet but as
you're about to hang up
someone leaves the building
i'll scream
[Laughter]
so the door opens and he looks at the
camera and it walks in no
walks in no no no i'm going down the
fire escape that's his yard now
it looks like i'm paying rent on two
yards because i don't live there
apparently so i just don't live there
anymore
i'm escaping that's hilarious he could
never say he's
he's gone transatlantic to find me
oh fam that's his yard
enjoy it
oh that's too funny
i would
let's say my yard seventh floor let's
set my head at 79
and the yards like the couple yards
let's say there's two yards on the floor
and like 78 is the one one or whatever
and see if i can knock off the nine and
the eight on our doors and swap them
round in the time in the seventh in the
one minute it takes him to get up the
flight of snapchat yeah you've got
bravery on you fam i'm not doing that
because i'm just assuming he's gonna be
here any second
and if he catches me doing that's even
worse for me he's gonna stab you on the
spot hundred percent he's gonna tie you
up his head hundred percent i'll tell
him he'll come into a post-it that said
bins go out on tuesdays
fyi
beans go out on tuesdays please feed my
cat let's meet in the freezer
make yourself up make yourself at home
airbnb bam the password is one two three
you'll you're coming wi-fi password is
patterned cutlery's ready to go meet in
the freezer bins go out on tuesdays it's
your yard i don't want any of this i
said it looks like i'm payment on two
yards now bro i wouldn't know what the
[ __ ] to do fam
i'll just be texting her abuse
i'd better on the spot oh 100
you'd better she'd lock off straight
away
i wouldn't know what expression to
express
i actually wouldn't know what to do
i wouldn't know what to do suitcase you
know i'm going to the closest precinct
and i'm getting him out my yard
but i don't know what connections he's
got in the u.s that's what makes it
worse so i don't even know if i
i don't know if i can go to the feds
and tell them what i don't know them and
then i'm just i'm a racist also now yeah
because because any japanese brother
i'll walk into the if i walk into a
police station and it happens to be a
japanese brother behind reception i'm
leaving
you man are all connected
[Music]
the fear that will run through yeah
the paranoia will bring the racist out
of me oh my taste it's mad
so yeah i don't know bro what would you
do
are you answering the telecom are you
just staying in there forever
oh no i wouldn't answer it until
i won't answer it whatsoever okay i
won't answer it whatsoever until it
stops ringing i'd run to the thing once
it stops ringing oh okay i was to be
fair i would stay there watch it watch
it watch it watch it ring watch it i
wouldn't answer it whatsoever and you
see him come in once i see him come
through the door there's two options
let's say i don't have
an actual fire escape like a back door
i have a plan
to see whether he takes the stairs or
take the lift okay and then i'm patting
it from there all right if he takes this
if he takes the lift i think it'd be a
lot easier for me to obviously run down
if you take the stairs
with a suitcase i probably have enough
time to say lift but i'm trying to think
whether i should just jump out the
[ __ ] window makes sense to you do you
know what i mean because i'll be that
shook
i mean that shook because i won't know
whether he's taking the stairs until i
know yeah you know imagine i'm pressing
the press lift and it opens up and he's
there oh my god you're [ __ ] i open the
lift and he's there he's got a picture
of me so he knows what i look like
he knows what i look like
i'll drop to my knees
i'll jump to my knees and tell him bro
please man please bro
i don't want this life please bro i
didn't i literally didn't do anything i
just asked her who you were
no bro long story short you're not the
[ __ ] man that's that's wild stuff
yeah why is it i wouldn't be about it
whatsoever bro yeah before that's
terrifying terrifying that's terrifying
[ __ ]
i wouldn't be about it bro please i'll
say please bro
i'll make you teppanyaki whatever you
want
um that's hilarious right so we're a bit
late to this one
but i want to to mention
bad gal riri's back on the mark
no i think that was thus that was funny
they're saying it's fluff but i don't
know if it is bro that's folklore bro
nah i want i want to believe it's real
nice folk man that's that's all gas
that's all gas bro
but um
anyway
whilst it was all going around it made
me not made me realize i always knew but
it just reinforced the knowledge that
like
females like when you read like female
responses or comments or hear like their
opinion on it they genuinely genuinely
genuinely don't get it
that guys don't cheat to upgrade um oh
when you were saying about he's cheating
with someone else yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah when people are how could you cheat
on rihanna like he's lost out on this
amazing person and then like he's never
going to beat anyone he's never going to
find someone penguin rihanna first of
all course he is
is asap rocky yeah
he beats penguin girls and rihanna every
friday saturday and sunday if you wanted
to if he wants to
like this is a ridiculous thing to say
yeah and secondly he's like he doesn't
need our money like he just like
rihanna's banging of course of course i
would die to be rihanna but if i was
asap rocky i'd probably cheat as well
yeah
yeah he's asap rocky yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but um
yes it's like women truly truly truly
truly do not understand that guys don't
cheat to upgrade of course because i
think a lot of times women do cheat to
upgrade of course like that i've spoken
to a lot of women when they're like i
would never [ __ ] a guy that's not better
looking than my partner like that
doesn't make sense and that's not why
men cheat oh they just cheat to cheat
they just cheat because they've seen a
pair of teeth
and that's just facts
that's literally just facts
yeah there's no comparison to your and
that's the that's the thing as well is
like that do you know
but obviously cheating's horrible anyway
how disrespectful it is to like she's
paying them my girl i'm gonna bang her
what's that about that's disrespect
that's so disrespectful
that's so disrespectful and the fact
that they think that they're doing
something noble by saying i would never
[ __ ] a guy that's not paying it's like
the fact that you would only [ __ ]
someone who's better looking than me is
so rude and disrespectful you have no
idea how rude that is
how do you think that makes me feel
literally
literally he's better than my man i'm
going to [ __ ] him oh
no we just see tv we just see titties or
cheeks on saturn and just like
and then also the lashes lips
yeah that's all it is yeah it's
specifics we would never compare it to
our girls
who would literally do such a thing it's
[ __ ] up
but yeah man it's just like yeah when i
see all them things like right these men
don't get it these men don't get it it
doesn't matter if it's rihanna it
doesn't matter who it is
if he's gonna do it he's going to do it
he's going to do it if she's going to do
it she's going to do it as well
but it's just yeah she yeah
yeah before she got pregnant she's well
she's been doing it she's been doing
it's rihanna she does what she wants
she does what she wants she does what
she wants who she wants when she wants
where she wants that's rihanna
these men live a different lifestyle
they do because man
i'll have her pregnant or not
i'll have her pregnant or not
i'm not going to bang on while she's
pregnant
i'm not going to bang
okay but yeah yeah i'll be there and
birthing classes though i'll be there
just fam literally
oh
that's just me
that's hilarious i'll be there man but
uh yeah that's what yeah apparently it's
all folklore but i don't necessarily
think there's that's a um
it's a very
high caliber couple for them to even
admit even if it was true
um i mean
yes and no i feel like
regardless of who you are in society
today if
folklore has come about about your name
or your partner's name
you're going to have to address it
regardless of who you are i don't know i
don't think this is saying anything
that's true bro it's not that there's
obviously they have addressed it but
they've addressed and said it's not true
well i'm saying if it is true i think
they're still going to say it's not true
she's pregnant for [ __ ] sake facts to
be fair
i don't even
i didn't even see them address it i saw
the chick address yeah that's to be fair
that's the thing that's come out is the
yet that they assumed it was with has
come out said nah that's all we know
yeah yeah we don't know if they're
together or not
she was banging as well of course she
was banging them says rocky yeah it's a
asap rocket that's a fashion mogul
sometimes some girls don't understand it
somebody has to start to say he does
what he wants when he wants if he
it is literally wild we'll see what
unfolds within the next few months
fam legitimately literally let's move on
we'll see what happens we ain't got a
choice but to find out
um
scenario no
oh
funny enough guess who gave me the
scenario koji gave me the scenario he
messaged me the other day koji messaged
you and said here's a scenario what not
just that but we were talking and he
just hit me with the scenario all right
i'll say it to james all right scenario
scenario let's say in this jesus let's
say in the
scenario um
it's terrible no i'm just saying this
whole affair has gone terrible
let's say you've got a three-year-old
kid in this scenario and
the crux is
you have to leave this kid
okay no the kids the misses everyone you
have to cut all ties
but every year
you have no contact with the family and
the kid or whatever you get 10 million
pounds
and to sweeten the pot
the day you leave you get 10 million so
you don't have to wait a year to receive
the first 10 10 mil the day you leave
you receive 10 m's but if you ever speak
to them once you've received the 10 m's
you get shot in your foot oh okay you
get shot in your [ __ ] but i've still
got the ten minutes you've got the 10
m's from the day you leave you get the
10 m's
and i've been there since the news
you've been there you've been there for
your whole you've lived your whole life
no conditions nothing
but you
someone's holiday you get an email you
get a phone call but it's legit
[ __ ] legit they've shown past
experiences other people
legit squid games legit they've done it
in the past before they've got real
people showing the real money in
everything
and they say james
we're calling on you next i want you to
leave your family and leave your newborn
i will give you 10 m's a year every year
i want to push you to your limits i want
to see what you're made of i want to see
how far you can go for this money and if
you think you're taking his money back
to your family bang i've got your first
gone we know everything about you
oh okay are they killing me or they're
just shooting me in my fur no no no in
the sense of you trying to contact them
look you trying to contact your family
oh that's what the phone's tapped into
you've got
once you agree once you say all right
boom you've got 24 hours to decide once
you agree
there's no turning back oh okay cool no
that's for me bro i'm not glad it's no
brainer
i'm leaving
taking my first installment coming back
these men will break through my yard and
my foot will be ready
shoot it
shoot it
[ __ ] shoot it
how many times to shoot just once
so where you're going to take the storm
and come back the next day yeah
i'll come back tomorrow
with bags in my account they're going to
shoot your [ __ ] yank on the money
back oh that's what i'm asking you do i
keep the money or not not after day one
brother
not after day one so i have to have
spent it yeah
yeah all right let's let's sweeten the
pot
let's say let's change up let's say you
they give you on the first day you say
yes they give you five m's and then the
other five at the end of the one year
and then after every year after that is
10 10 10 10. oh okay so let's say
you you take you agree you say yes
you've they've given you five mil you go
away you're on your merry journeys for
every month so let's say you've come
back within the first month they'll take
off
250 bags
another month or any form of contacts
oh they deduct 250. two hot handle ting
250 bags
250 250 250 250 and if you come home
they're taking 2.5
jesus
um
and you're still getting shot in the leg
okay
um
nah i'll i'll stay if i've been with
them for three years yeah
i'm staying bro and obviously you can
never tell them while gone yeah yeah i'm
stay i'm staying like [ __ ] your money
but am i in dire straits
or do i have the second biggest podcast
in the world no you're you want you are
not james of the pod
i'm suffering you're james in sales
sales and accounting i'm just shaking at
the table every day
and my wife doesn't even rate me you're
[ __ ] scrubbing your car at 6 00 am
trying to get the snow off
that james from four years ago five
years ago that's the james you are okay
and i'm getting five mil the day i leave
that five mil the day you leave and five
mil one year after and then ten mil
every year after that
cool
i'm gonna take my five m's
i'm gonna bail them and be like this is
for the greater good you can't tell them
a thing i know i'm gonna bail them
because she says 250 every contact
this is for the greater good i'll see
you in six months
this is for the greater good you'll
believe me i'm going to see you in six
months
it's going to be hell on both of us
it hurts me as much as it wait for me
just wait for me
i'm [ __ ] mean it wait for me this
course cost me 250. don't ask me
anything else
click
that's what i'm doing take my five m's
take 250 off me i'll take that so i've
got what uh four seven yeah
um take my four seven live the next six
months take my next money
so throughout that time i'm investing at
least three million of this
and then i'll get my other five mil in
six months time right end of the year
end of the year i'll have to wait for
the whole year
every 12 months brother so you get the
five m's so it's ten year it's ten mil
every year but because you've just
signed up you get five meal now and then
the other five meal by the end of that
first year then every other year after
that is ten mil on the dot yeah okay
fair enough every six months all right
then um
[ __ ] oh because a year is a long time
six months a long time is a [ __ ] long
time you've missed a lot oh yeah i don't
think i could do it you know um i think
probably i would
yeah i'm taking my money
investing it wisely
i'll call i'll still take the l on the
250. do my call invest all my money
come back to yards get shot in my foot
and i'll be back
and i'll be vex about it
because i yeah because i'm just going to
get disrespected for the next few months
yeah
how could you do this yeah yeah how
could you do these things yeah yeah but
when the cash flow starts paying off and
we're living different now yeah then she
might forgive me but uh yeah i think
that's what i do fair i'll be gone until
the money is invested and we've got a
solid cash flow then however long it
takes a few weeks few months i'm back
cool what would you do i'll do first 24
hours
let's say they failed me and they said
i've got 24 hours to decide or whatever
during those 24 hours i'm doing research
i'm finding ex participants yeah yeah
yeah yeah
interviewing them
i'm going to ask them how real is this
threat
how real is this threat
because i need to know the severity of
it
and do they mean what they say and they
say what they mean yeah because
yeah yeah that shot in the foot thing
yeah how many men have you how many of
you of you men have been shot in the
foot yeah yeah that's why i asked a
group of them yeah yeah yeah if a couple
of them raised their hand i'm like yo
this is real i've got the bandage i've
got the works but i've also got the five
m's i can show you my account right now
yeah yeah my eyes would widen
the greed will come into play
you know what i mean
yeah
especially when you meet you know
survivors
you'll meet the thing is is you'll
interview someone yeah who's got that
five and you'll be thinking [ __ ] and
then you'll see someone else who's got
30.
and they're living different
i didn't think about that i would think
about the next six months yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you met someone who had five
and you had someone who's got 30 yeah
and he's like what is it
five that's [ __ ] cute so man spent
three years without his family yeah ten
wow
i actually don't think i could do it no
i don't think i could for this the 31 i
definitely don't think i can do that i
don't think i can go three years well i
know i couldn't go three years without
talking to my immediate family as well
as my extended family like let's say
i've got the kids and blah blah that
media family as well as like my parents
sister brother i could never do it i
don't think i could that is a suffering
there's a different type of suffering
especially once you've got that five m's
it's like a year it's a long [ __ ]
time
and you're rich now anyway
and you're just what are you doing
i think what i'll do
is
i will try my luck
but i'll probably get everyone killed
yeah i mean okay i would secure the five
m's i'll accept that i've accepted it
yeah yeah i've done exactly what you did
i bought my missus
listen
and listen good
you're not going to be about for a
minute yeah don't ask me why
but just no
it's for the greater good yeah it's not
safe for you
it's not safe for you and it's not safe
for us
as long as you want to keep junior safe
yeah don't contact me yeah yeah
yeah you will understand but don't
contact me
lock off the phone say let's see the 5ms
all right boom i'll start looking for
flights yeah
incognito incognito flights yeah yeah
yeah yeah at like dick o'clock on a
thursday evening yeah it's a mozambique
sighting random like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'll buy four or five tickets
or rouletting they don't know which one
you'll go
i'll buy bagger tickets yeah tickets
yeah yeah like we're all under different
names yeah bagger tickets yeah yeah all
right okay cool this one go and four on
the same day different airports [ __ ]
out all right different airports same
city different airports yeah yeah yeah
and we'll probably we'll fly from like
aberdeen or something oh you wanna
you're gonna catch me if i can't grab
the whole family
mimi and aberdeen tuesday 12 p.m if
you're not there be square
and we're out
we're out
brother yeah
you see me in kauai chilling yeah yeah
yeah yeah chilling yeah yeah yeah it
makes sense and that makes sense until
they catch me yeah that's i'm not i'm
dashing my phone in a bin no social
media the pod is over
none of that
i'll be done bro you've got energy film
i would just hold a bullet in my foot i
can't be bothered for that i can't hold
the bullet james yeah i know you can't
just i don't have time for stuff like
that that's your fear i'll [ __ ] hold
it i'm not running around i'm not
running around different continents
trying to escape always looking over my
shoulder just shoot me [ __ ] shoot i
can't live like that you never know who
the bread is going to be
you're going corner shop i might just
click before you [ __ ] got away
imagine you [ __ ] thought you got away
yeah you [ __ ] you were playing
you thought we were playing
run with my five m's back now yeah
i've spent loads aberdeen yeah
six o'clock yeah if i was a [ __ ]
idiot before you want to cook it
you'll be white as a ghost family
family i beg
i beg the donny behind the counter to
save me
oh my god oh my god that's hilarious
[ __ ] all of that ah i've got another
scenario for you hit me
i've got my slaughter for you this is um
i actually saw this one online the other
day
someone gives you 30 mil yeah but then
the next day
your mum needs eye surgery cause it's 20
90 yeah and the left eye costs 29 mil
what you do
the right eye is fine it's just there's
a gangrene in the left she's got
gangrene in a car accidentally yeah 29
mil and she'll have perfect vision
do we have time to barter or no yeah
we've got time to barter yeah but the
thing's tomorrow
the cut-off dates tomorrow for the
surgery and i'd ask donnie is there no
other price point there's no negotiation
there's 29 mil so there's no bar in
there what are she's talking about oh i
feel you with your mom
because that's what i'll be doing i'll
be battling with her how bad you'd need
to see fam she's gonna have to wear that
eye patch yeah 20 what's 20 20
what is 20 20 really it was a [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's a [ __ ] you've had [ __ ] 55
years of 2020 you've got less than that
to go
i said one more if i spend all this
money on you and you [ __ ] get hit by
a bus on the way out what's what's up
you're not thinking about these things
what are you thinking about is your
stinking eye what do you think about
yourself yeah yeah
we could if
you could you might only be able to see
half of it but the half you're going to
see is going to be lavish for the rest
of your life lavish
we're getting a young glass eye ting
yeah
yeah no one will know the difference and
you'll just get used to it
i don't think i could i couldn't run 29
m's on eye surgery and me left with one
wait how have i gotten this thumbnail
did i win it yeah not every
that's different then i guess um you
didn't work for it okay
um
i don't know
29.
what surgery is this bruv that's all
i'll be thinking what are they doing to
her you're so african what are you doing
to her
what surgery is this
these are the questions i'll be asking
you
so expensive
walk me through the procedure
because i need to understand what you're
doing with my 29ers um you don't need to
understand nothing you need to
understand if you want your mum to see
or not she can't say if i was the
surgeon that's what i say to you you're
giving all this this is my knife surgery
today
you're boring me
you're holding up the line talking about
explaining expenditure if you're broke
say you're broke and leave
so there's mandate just lining up yeah
there's rich [ __ ] behind you that are
trying to see so if you don't want to be
in this
leave
i'm the only doctor that can make this
work yeah
i've been up here in geneva just fixing
eyes and you're just chatting about
expensive expensive to you experience if
you're too expensive for you
then leave
no
i promise you now james first of all
he's not getting my 29 names my mom's
gonna have to see with one eye she's
gonna have to second of all i'm going to
geneva the next day
because there's no one that can speak to
me like that
there's no doctor that could speak to me
like that and make me think i'm poor
yeah yeah when i have to say he ends in
my pocket yeah yeah yeah i'd ruin his
whole surgery
i've ruined his whole practice
for the thing he's got security oh yeah
he would have he's got security he's got
nine procedures today
your 29 is baby money to him
baby money that's different security i
didn't think about that yeah he's got
platoons family i didn't think about
that come to geneva if you're bad oh
with your 29 q little m's
[ __ ]
fan now stay money then
uh your mum will never respect you again
i'll just have to apologize she'll be
fine will she well okay let's just say
she was actually begging you though that
is very different there that's very
different it says she came to you and
was like who had i know this is a lot of
money i know this is so much money i
know it's pretty much your entire net
worth but i i need my i i can't i'm so
scared i'm so scared please don't break
me i'll do it
that'll break me immediately same i'll
kiss my teeth and do it
i will kiss my teeth and do it yeah and
i'm stuck with one m for the rest of my
life oh break me brother livid live what
can i do with whatever
for 50 years what can i do with that
nothing
nothing i might as well never won it
people kill themselves over stuff
true
[ __ ] it out oh god ah
we've we've done well with the scenarios
today yes
tragic i'll do it but i'll be so i'll
guilt tripper forever
i'll guilty forever crocodile tears
ah you're savage bro no i'm joking i'm
playing you're savage um
i've got signing to read out to you okay
it's a um
it's a
thread it was a twitter thread but it's
on instagram
and it's about orgies obviously we're
talking about on the um
patreon episode last week
but i wanted to speak about that but i
couldn't find the tweet i couldn't find
the the ting okay i found it now just
have a listen to this
let's talk about the underground atlanta
orgies have you guys ever been to one i
have here's my story
for my 30th birthday two years ago my
bff suggested we should go to one she's
a big freak i'm not though but i was
curious
we signed up to this secret website and
had to fill out a bunch of paperwork
then we had to go and get tested once we
submitted everything and we were good to
go we got a special invite to the show
so we got a special invite to show up to
the secret address
the orgy was on saturday night
at this warehouse all the way out in
lithonia i was scared as hell but but i
said to myself yolo every everything
started around 7pm walked inside we were
frisked by security and then taken to a
different area to take off our clothes
this is terrifying
this is terrifying
sent to an area to take off our clothes
we were then taken to a different area
as soon as we walked inside the
semi-dark room i saw like 400 people
just [ __ ] each other
craziest thing ever some weird music was
playing while nothing but moans and
groans filled the air room smelled of
roses and incense
it was like babylon
[Music]
i felt jokes
i felt weird
i felt weird and guilty
i almost wanted to leave but then this
dude with his 10 inch dick came out of
nowhere and started kissing me on the
neck
he was sexy as hell he took my hand and
walked me over to the couch an hour
later i had four other dudes dicks up in
me all types of drugs and alcohol were
passed around i popped an x and went
even crazier
i think that night i had like 200 dudes
come up in me condoms were optional oh
my word i l the orgy went on for like 10
hours
left the warehouse the next morning at 7
am i slept like two days in a row
afterwards no cap but there were some
celebrities there too
only regret i have is i wish i would
have known that i wish i would have
known about orgies before i got married
my hubby was aware on a business trip he
figured money was more important than my
birthday while 200 200 other [ __ ]
showed me just how important that
weekend was
wild brother i'll tell you what's really
wild
is that
after all of that
she still found a way to blame on her
husband
she found a way to bring her justified
[ __ ] 200 guys and make it her
husband's fault
wow
hilarious bro
to be fair
you know we've we've had a lot of chat
about like could you do a sex part or
stuff like that mm-hmm as soon as she
said i popped an x i was thinking that's
what would get me yeah that's what we're
getting
yeah yeah give me some ex i've never had
it but give me some ecstasy i'm sure
i'll be ready to party
i'm sure i'll be ready to party bro i'm
sure too that's nuts
that's wild this is a real thing in
atlanta
fam
i'm not going to lie to her bro at the
beginning i i wouldn't be on it
petrified bro
frisk down and take him to another room
to take clothes your clothes off
is this auschwitz family is this is this
jail this is nazi germany
what are you doing
what are we doing frisking me and saying
take your clothes off over there no no
no no no i'll say fan we're going i'd
rip up the contract yeah we're going bro
where's the romance
where's the [ __ ] roman romance is
next door yeah yeah yeah romance is
through those doors take your [ __ ]
clothes i honestly think i would vomit
if i saw 400 people [ __ ] in one room
open the door and all you hear is moans
and glory i think i would fight and i
swear to god i vomit and that would not
turn me on firm because 50 is just dick
in there i don't want to hear breasts
bro i don't want to hear it
i don't want to hit guys in there bro
200
200 in there
just bare decibels
and i'm naked as well
no man
i have to pop an extra i'd have to pop
an x you have to pop a next order i'd
have to pop an egg yeah
then
then i i'm pretty sure i could filter
all of that out
oh [ __ ] out but yeah she said one
dude with a 10 incher just came and
kissed her neck that's all she needed
that's all she she saw 10 inches said
she got banged for 10 hours did she say
that's outrageous i wouldn't get the
full benefit of this
because i would not one time and i'd be
like cool i'm out i'm literally out
what a waste of time
time and money
seven minutes in and i'm tired
i'm literally done
[ __ ]
that is hilarious it really is condoms
were optional condoms were optional
right guys uh we've come to the
second most important part of the show
last week we asked you guys what's the
pettiest reason you stopped talking to
somebody
and you have
the responses here i'm ready
i've this i think this is the most i've
written so i'm just going to literally
go back to back to back you can laugh
you cannot laugh your business i'm going
back to back to back to back all right
bet go cool
i matched on tinder and the first thing
she said
you could be taller
mind you i'm 6'3
you could be taller
he wore shorts and his legs looks like
crutches
[Laughter]
yo
[ __ ] that made me dizzy i was not
expecting that
oh
[ __ ] now that's funny that's actually
very funny
he was playing with my belly thinking it
was my tit oh my god that sounds like a
you problem i'm not gonna lie as i was
like a you probably look
that's hilarious
um
next one he had triceps like adama
triure do you know who that is oh my god
context hilarious
so before i show you the spreader right
yeah yeah he used to play for wolves
okay he's spanish born yeah yeah bread
but now he plays for barcelona all right
he's just muscular yeah and he always
oils himself up so man can't slide off
him he can't grab him so he slides off
he's right i'll have some yeah i've seen
him play
he's a striker yeah yeah i've seen him
play for walls before yeah
yeah
why christ
that was the reason she stopped talking
to him
he just like kidded it
[ __ ] know she wasn't about it she's
too wham saw trying something yeah as a
threat yeah
he's abusive
he needs something to do with all that
power
because he's not scoring goals
he yeah i said he put he he instead of
haha facts
i'm colorblind stinks a bird on my bed
she left i mistook the blood for [ __ ]
stains
oh god
he had no name trainers on
wow what where did you get that sam no
idea like primark or saying probably to
be fair he was wearing plimp souls
probably to be fair do you remember when
like years ago when primark went through
that phase where they had exact replica
vans yes of course i do mad i never got
any i did did you i got a few
they were cheaper
they were headed they were like three
pounds
they look exactly like that they didn't
last long
i bet they they fell [ __ ] apart
i didn't like the style of boxes he wore
out here looking like bananas in pajamas
do you remember that show
i'm running down the stairs and chasing
teddy bears
i
remember that basically said of course i
remember
he brought a travel sized sun cream on
our first date so his bold head didn't
burn oh
[ __ ] she's wearing hat brother
his surname starts with a and i can't
have a kid being the first one to do
orals at school oh my god
fair that's joe she's thinking ahead
that's yeah that's
she's thinking ahead oh dear
mispronounced pop smoke as bob smoke
he had to go yeah dash
he had a hair transplant and it wasn't
taking
that's my worst fear
listen to me that's my worst fit i don't
know how well
always on tick tock i always see like oh
here's my transplant transformation like
yeah yeah diary whatever the [ __ ] and
like even three months in it's still
obvious that you've had a hedgehog i'm
thinking i can't go this long i don't
think it's [ __ ] long
it'll feel like a lifetime acting you
probably can't wear hats with time oh
you must have covered it can't cover it
for months nah i'm not doing dancing i'm
not doing that you can't have proper
shots people have to like do left yeah
i'm not doing it
i don't know how rooney did it he did it
over like the the um not international
break the season break
and um didn't think he did as well
wasn't lebron do as well lebron's didn't
take fam lebron's is an absolute
shambles jesus that's what testosterone
takes fair
she told me she was lactose and tolerant
instead of lactose intolerant
that's stuff that i will cut someone off
for miss speaking we just don't
understand
you just don't understand [ __ ]
pisses me off i didn't write this one
down but there was another one similar
to this it said he used the word
contents instead of context
so when she put in breakfast she
couldn't even use context in the right
context
bro my one is the um
specifically
i've written that here specifically he
wrote pacific instead of specific bro
pacific i've got that on here as well
[ __ ] pisses me off i'm done with you
yeah yo oh [ __ ] it up
he was smaller than he looked in his
picks
and i had to bend down to give him a
kiss i'm five six
wow he's small but is he though
is he she had to bend down
my assumption i'm trying to give him the
benefit of the doubt i'm taking a big
picture
so my assumption is they were on a date
they linked
she's obviously wearing heels okay she's
naturally five six she put on a heel
with a young three or four inches made
of five nine five ten okay he's a young
five seven five eight that's not been
downting foul
an inch is
inches like this big that's not bend
down
she could be exaggerated of course she's
exaggerated she's a liar
but i think he's small
she did not bend down to kiss him i'm
telling you that now
because that's like clinical now
that's clinically short
no there's a name for that
i'm just gonna say there's a name for
that there's a name for that oh my days
that's hilarious
she started making tick tocks about me
wow that's not a petty reason to cut
someone off
i would call you off oh 100
you have to be cut off would you mean
you're making tick tocks about me i
would cut her off immediately
his facebook profile pick was him
holding a coin on a cob
he sent subpar shirtless picks with the
caption enjoy kiss my friends now call
him charity work
[Music]
imagine find out that your nickname is
charity work i couldn't i'm burning
things to the ground i don't know what
and i don't know who and i don't know
when nations but things are burning yeah
call me putin
things are burnt i'll be [ __ ] angry
because
in hindsight there's nothing you can do
you're a joke and you're gonna stay a
joke so i have your tantrum have your
attention have your little tantrum
oh
wow that would infuriate me
he had he had smaller feet than me oh
fam i used to work with a prayer he was
a bit short he was probably like five
five ready four four five four five five
okay he literally had like size five
feet damn
so he used to get kids trainers
he had kids trainers damn anybody i had
because he had no shame about it he was
like bro he's cost me like 30 quid
and i was like damn he saved a buck
fair enough
painted our initials on a rock and gave
it to me at my work in a busy bar
here's the rock
with our initials on it
that's a spectrum thing
i'm just going to throw out sounds like
a love on the spectrum thing
he licked my face and thought it was
erotic oh
dear
we took a tram somewhere and because
he's small instead of stepping onto the
platform he jumped
he jumped
[ __ ] sake every traffic light he came
up to turn red and he had to stop and it
gave him the it
[Laughter]
women don't care they don't they've got
so many options they just don't give a
[ __ ] i don't care about you
he had to stop at the traffic lights so
i was done with him
wow one of these balls was double the
size of the other it was too much for me
i ended the first day early because a
voice sounded like a dirt bike
[Laughter]
to be fair i think after watching the
ultimatum yeah with what's her face
lauren did we say it was lauren with the
tax i think a voice is enough to stop me
talking to a girl i couldn't
sexualize her after i heard her to be
honest because i binged it so quickly
and laurel was in it only oh she was
being gone earlier i can't even remember
what our voice sounds like it's annoying
he left the white episode two three two
or three yeah
he's annoying oh so
i honestly don't remember
referred to his tool as a sledgehammer
where he was barely equipped with four
inches
how did okay question
how do women know the reference point
for these inches
how do they know how what the i don't
know how many inches mine is
how do they just know how do they look
at a dick and blade that's a four incher
that's a five because i mean
like dildos
oh good point my assumption yeah but
they're not getting four inch dildos
yeah but obviously they've probably got
like a six or seven inch dildo so they
didn't gauge they gain or take away
maybe
maybe that's a good point
that's my assumption anyway
he didn't have a tv in his room and said
we could watch something on his phone
not even an ipad on phone his phone
can you imagine i'd [ __ ] roll over
and sleep
i'd drag all the duvet as well you [ __ ]
phone
that's poverty
that's poverty
we can watch something on my phone
no let the things you have to bypass to
get to phone i know no tv no laptop no
pc no ipad ipad no ipad mini
phone no psp no nintendo switch a random
tablet yeah any old tab any amazon fire
stick nighting
phone
wow
wow yeah bruh
he had posted notes of motivational
quotes all over his bedroom walk
ah sad
his roof leaked
[ __ ] off
i kissed her and she had the saltiest
lips she's now tick-tock famous i
fumbled the bag
i don't care i'm i'm not lipsticking you
i'm not i'm not staying with you think
you're famous or not you could be better
porsche while i care
if your lips are salty i don't even know
how he identified that
no no we're done salty salty lips we're
done yuck
he was bald under that hat
tough
his teeth were fighting for position in
his mouth
i can't imagine how crooked they were
yeah that's marked oh
i told him i told him to knock down my
throat in my ass he said uh no tits or
nothing
excuse me i lied excuse me brother
excuse me
not the options were not down my throat
or anything not on in my arse he said
tits or nothing i said nah tits or
nothing
who are you who does he think he is
that
who are you
he hasn't got his head screwed up he
doesn't are you jason momoa he doesn't
know what's what
uh um no um no
tits or nothing else like babes i'm not
even tits or nothing
wow in my ass and he said um no
down my throat or in my ass not even in
my mouth down my throat
not even in my no one's
ever asked me to not in their ass no
one's ever
ever it's never happened
it's never happened
unless i was already in there and they
said hurry up enough
it's never happened
no hang on i'm fixated not down my
throat or in my ass and he said neither
neither i want mt's i have to rate him i
have to i have to rate the man that's
what he wants
because i'll be stuck for choices i'm
definitely gonna ask
i just said i'll be stuck
because that's a rare treat
that's a devil fruit
oh i you can't
[Laughter]
yeah
you can't turn that down
wow
all right oh god
in high school
in high school
i caught a girl i was interested in
drinking porridge from a thermos oh
jesus christ
yuck ally yuck a lie
the way they kiss their teeth silently
no sound just pout
that's funny
i can literally see it
when he took off his shoes he wasn't
wearing any socks
that's buzzed
bars bro
i'm all for no body shaming
but his tall was so small
it was like stirring soup with a single
spaghetti
[Music]
wow
what an analogy family a single
spaghetti i read that on the train down
here yeah as soon as i read that i
looked up i just looked out the window
because i had to take a second
that's like enveloping him that's insane
a single spaghetti
context wow
he stopped talking to me because i
didn't watch the tour de france
that's funny this next one this is how
you know mandem have just pat in the
painting last night and want to keep the
conversation going
he asked me how my day was going at 8am
he's out of his league
he's [ __ ] panicking
[Laughter]
how's your day going oh he's panicking
he's panicking he's never seen anything
like it he needs to make sure she's
still entertained yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ] it up
he had a single bed fair enough all
right yeah it's fair he had a michael
jordan quilt cover he's 35. oh dear poor
yeah
he said he couldn't stand the smell of
butter
all right fair play
is that fair play
i'm just i don't know fam butter doesn't
really smell of much it's not it doesn't
it doesn't his tongue was too white
manky ick okay cool
yeah [ __ ] off that's disgusting that's
[ __ ] just stinks
yeah
definitely stinks and you get that white
spit when you're ranting you get that
white spit here
that goes from the top zip to the bottom
to the top
back up
his tongue was too white oh
scrape that i woke up in the morning to
cuts on my legs from his unnecessary
long toenails
yuck wow
saw him naked for the first time his bum
had no meat at all i was freaked out
[Laughter]
bro
flat battery is a gender
like neutral problem
it's a gender-neutral problem it is it's
fun no one likes it yeah it is
no matter what that one like
she kiss she kisses her brother on the
lips every time they see each other bye
i said it that he said pacific instead
of pacific i said that earlier
he sent me a video of him lip syncing in
his work uniform
yuck
very arc
this one sent me he voiced his voice
cracked in a voice mode and he sent it
to me anyway
best believe i'm deleting it and
starting again
the first two seconds i really know my
voice 100
100 percent i'm gonna do my me me me
yeah even if i have to restart the laugh
fab yeah
you know
yeah yeah yeah
that's jokes still me yeah that was
right you're actually funny you know i
have to restart the laugh bro i've done
that on numerous occasions so if i were
no shame [ __ ] i've got no shame that
would never know that yeah they'll never
know it's an original love yeah it's
authentic
she couldn't spell the word restaurant
spell restaurant right now
spell restaurant right [ __ ] now
smell restaurants stop thinking that's
about it yes
p-e-c-t no no
r-e-s-t-a-u
r-a-n-t
is it
is it
yes
scared me but i'm not gonna lie scared
me
i'm thinking if we get us wrong
there's no edit we can do to get me
right
[ __ ] oh god he picked up his steak with
his hands at dinner oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
it would scare the life oh 100
imagine you're on a date with her
hangers and she just picks up she's
ordered a rib eye medium it comes with
all the compliments whatever barbecue
barbecue sauce peppercorn sauce whatever
like tuck it yeah back to that
and she just grabs it
wow
i would have to look for cameras because
i'm on punctual sign same satin she's an
animal she's an ad i'll bang her in the
toilet and leave
because it's the animal yeah there's
something in there
there's a there's a side to you i want
to meet yeah and then i never want to
speak to you again there's something i
like about yeah
yeah let me find out yeah yeah that's
hilarious
ah
he was a hardcore one direction fan wow
[ __ ] me all right
after i drove his car
he had to push the seat forward to get
to the pedals shameful we spoke about
that before
shameful
that is
he had to call for directions because he
didn't have data for google maps
cool who i have no idea probably the
link
can you imagine linking the thing and if
she told you i don't have credit
i couldn't
i actually couldn't i ain't got credit
i didn't even know credit was still a
thing i only recently learned a couple
like weeks ago that credit is actually
still a thing i didn't know instead of
thing
credit
oh can you call me back please i don't
have credit
you don't have ambitions to take
yourself forward oh 100 credit
yeah 100 and we're of similar age groups
yeah 100 ready
he faded forward so he he lost
consciousness
his nose and you fought yuck and just
left
he's not a man
he thought the plural for moose was me
it's so mad that as soon as you said
moose i was thinking miss
and then last but not least we said this
earlier he bought clothes from the
junior section he must have been oh [ __ ]
danny must have been five five
oh
that was a that was a long one boy you
really did just rang them out fam i had
about seven to ten more screenshots of
different pages that i didn't finish wow
bro there was loads yeah these um
these instagram questions on a friday
they're getting busy they're getting i
always know you've done one because i'll
go onto our instagram and in the request
it will just say 99 plus
and i'm like oh [ __ ] it now oh [ __ ] it's
a lot in it yeah i'm just like you're
supposed to get free
i just end up scrolling looking for blue
ticks
is there anything urgent
that's hilarious bro that's hilarious um
but yeah man guys thank you for this one
yeah another long one you know another
longer i think these new chairs are
doing the thing
i think these new chairs are changing
the game another [ __ ] long one i hope
you guys like this one um
we'll see you again next week for the
guys that are
running the p
we'll definitely see you on thursday
gang gang members we'll see you on
thursday pussyclass we'll see you all
next monday all right love love love
[Music]
you